on va passer de la voile on va
maintenant parler du climat alors jean
jouzel son nom ne vous est peut-être pas
inconnu il a été co prix nobel de la
paix en 2007 avec le giec c'était le
groupement c'est le groupement d'études
sur le climat
il est d'ailleurs toujours
vice-président du giec jean jouzel a été
aussi directeur de l'i ps ltt l'institut
pierre simon laplace à l'université de
versailles saint quentin il conserve
d'ailleurs toujours un laboratoire et
jean jouzel vient de participer à une
conférence sur le réchauffement
climatique proposé par la fondation de
l'observatoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
il nous a accordé une interview bonsoir
jean jouzel
bon soit catherine vous êtes le
président du giec le groupement d'études
sur le climat et il faut le rappeler
vous êtes co lauréat du prix nobel de la
paix c'était en 2007
et puis vous travaillez toujours au sein
du laboratoire des sciences du climat et
de l'environnement au sein de l'ue de
lever ce qu on se trouve là ce soir
parce que vous êtes venu animer une
conférence avec une thématique je trouve
très très large
le réchauffement climatique où en est-on
où on était vaste
on a tout d'abord je tiens à préciser
que je suis vice président du groupe
scientifique du giec c'est vrai que je
suis impliqué dans jcs depuis une
vingtaine d'années maintenant et c'est
une année importante puisque nous sommes
nous avons en quelques mois publié le
cinquième rapport du giec qui
effectivement sert de référence nous
sert de dix ans de base commune toute la
communauté scientifique
la publication ses soeurs 2013 2014
c'est très important mais je continue
aussi avoir des recherches un peu moins
un peu près pas pour moi qu'il ne
faudrait peut-être et sur cette
cinquième édition du giec est ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu il ya
des bruits ce que je faisais annonce par
exemple à une augmentation des
températures de 4 degrés je crois que ça
restera oui malheureusement c'est mais
c'était déjà dans le 4e rapport du giec
à savoir que c'était déjà dans le
premier rapport du giec
si on émet des gaz à effet de serre sans
y prendre aucune mon attention et bien
dix ans 90 nous visions que après 2050
dans la deuxième partie du 21ème siècle
le climat se réchauffe ray de quatre
degrés de 3 4 degrés finalement qui les
rapports du siècle suivant était dans la
continuité on dit toujours un peu la
même chose
en réponse respecte mais précise oui je
crois que d'ailleurs c'est très bien je
crois que c'est un hommage la communauté
scientifique
les projections qui avait été fait il y
avait un temps reste tout à fait valable
évidemment les a précisé leur caractère
régional m'a beaucoup appris en une
vingtaine d'années
mais et c'est pour ça pour répondre à
votre question je crois pouvoir dire que
le cinquième rapport du giec sera dans
la continuité par exemple est donc les
modélisateurs français nous avons deux
deux modèles en france celui de la suite
du père simon laplace dont fait partie
le laboratoire des sciences du climat et
de l'environnement et celui de météo
france
les résultats étaient publiés et on voit
effectivement des réchauffements
importante
ça confirme ces chiffres si rien n'est
fait pour limiter les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors on va parler de ce
qui se faisait déjà parler du protocole
de kyoto parce qu'ils se hissent achève
la 1re phase s'achève au 31 décembre
2012 est d'abord si on dit aux gens
comme ça 4 degrés d'augmentation de
température finalement c'est pas grand
chose c'est plutôt même sympathique mais
non il ya des vraies conséquences nord
il ya il est vrai conséquence il ya des
vraies conséquences sont souvent une
image fait moi même
22 recherche sont plus les climats du
passé à paraître à partir des glaces
polaires et si on regarde la dernière
période glaciaire c'était il ya vingt
mille ans le niveau de la mer était de
220 mètres plus bas qu'actuellement et
tout cela parce qu'il y avait une énorme
quantité de glace qui était sur toute
l'amérique du nord
disons l'europe du nord la scandinavie
donc c'était un climat très très
différent du nôtre
mais en moyenne globale la température
n'était que de 5 à 6 degrés plus froides
qu'actuellement gros 4 degrés c'est les
deux tiers d'un d'un changement entre
périodes glaciaires et interglaciaires
mais là la nature mis des milliers
d'années sont à effectuer cette
transition plus de 5000 ans là nous
sommes en train de faire cela en moins
de cent ans une centaine d'années c'est
vraiment ça la différence
la capacité d'adaptation elles existent
mais les limites et on a de bonnes
raisons de penser que si le climat
excède saison 2 degrés c'est un peu une
barre symbolique et bien la capacité
d'adaptation devra vraiment commencera à
disparaître donc c'est vraiment égoïste
de notre part que de laisser alors on
parle même plus de générations futures
mais nos enfants et nos petits-enfants
planète avec un réchauffement de 4
degrés avec des conséquences par exemple
la semaine dernière un article sur les
forêts vit vraiment qu'avec les récits
des sécheresses à répétition bien 70%
des arbres des forêts seraient mis à mal
ils ont une grande modification des
écosystèmes en france des problèmes avec
eux on avait des temps diminution plus
importante des inondations sud de plus
en plus fréquemment oui des sécheresses
dans d'autres régions des extrêmes
climatiques plus fréquent par exemple on
a toutes les raisons de penser dans ce
contexte si rien n'était fait bien et
les vagues de chaleur deviendrait à la
fin du 21e siècle d'une fois plus
fréquentes qu'elles des têtes à la fin
du xxème siècle d'or c'est un climat
complètement différent aussi bien en
montagne c'est aussi d'élévation du
niveau de la mer
lesquels pourraient certainement
dépenser 50 cm à la fin du siècle mais
surtout se poursuivre par la suite donc
c'est tout cela c'est tout cela qui va
être au coeur des aussi des discussions
je vais à doha la semaine prochaine donc
effectivement une conférence call qui
s'est ouvert depuis le 26 novembre ils
vont faire quoi parce qu'une fois qu'on
appelait le constat une fois que la
chair qualité sont sales sont cinquièmes
document qui dit finalement rien ne
change
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et ce que le
protocole de kyoto qui était mis en
place depuis 2005 qui lave à sa gym au
31 décembre 2012
ça n'a pas été suffisant il faut aller
plus loin où il faut aller plus loin il
faut aller plus loin on tout le monde
sait ce qu'il faut faire puisque la
convention
le premier rapport du giec c'est 1990
1992 la convention climat signé au
sommet de la terre de rio il ya 20 ans
et déjà dans cette convention l'article
de disette façon très claire que on
devait tout faire pour stabiliser le
climat pour faire que cet effet de serre
qu'on rejette
gaz carbonique méthane autres gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère gay on
voit ici c'est en stabilisé le niveau
dans l'atmosphère donc ça c'était la
convention climat mais à copenhague donc
cette convention climat se réunit chaque
année nous en sommes disons à la 15e
réunion durant son climat la cop15 eh
bien disons lily l'idée c'est que pour
stabiliser les gaz et les quantités de
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
mais ce sont des véritables défis
doutons cac à copenhague
on est passé d'un objectif qualitatif
stabiliser l'effet de serre un objectif
chiffré à savoir que dix ont plus
donnent tout doit être fait pour que le
réchauffement climatique n'excède pas 2
degrés
lis on accepte jamais deux degrés de
réchauffement climatique lié aux
activités humaines
et ça c'est sain parce que ça
permettrait jeu pour l'essentiel de
s'adapter mais c'est un véritable défi
parce que ça sert ils ont ça requiert
que les quantités de gaz à effet de
serre commencent les émissions
commencent éliminer d'ici la fin de
cette décennie et soient ensuite
divisées par trois d'ici 2050
techniquement c'est possible c'est
possible d'aller donc c'est quoi le défi
c'est ce regard de l'an dernier 80% des
dix ans
pratiquement les trois quarts de
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre qu'on
a vu en 2011 est liée à notre
utilisation des combustibles fossiles
charbon pétrole et gaz naturel
donc il ya un lien très fort entre
énergie et climat c'est très clair donc
il faut absolument aller vers une
société sobre en carbone et 7e places
disons la philosophie de ce débat sur la
transition énergétique qui en fait a été
lancé officiellement cet après midi
donc c'est comment peut-on les vérifier
si ces sobres en carbone comment peut-on
au niveau français s'est inscrit dans la
loi
diviser nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par un facteur 4
donc c'est cela qu'il faut mettre en
route je pense avec mon ordi d'ailleurs
la section politique est-ce que c'est
aux industriels de faire quelque chose
tout le monde c'est particulier oui
aussi l'état je crois que pour lutter
enfin la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique passe par passe par des état
déterminé c'est à dire et ça je crois
que le rôle principal c'est justement là
où ils sont présents dans dans les
négociations c'est là que je pense qu'il
faut donner un prix au carbone il faut
effectivement
imposer disons je dirais en tout cas
aller s'imposer des objectifs sont
seulement un peu disons non plus ou
moins s'imposer des objectifs ce qu'ils
font parce qu'ils ont tous signé
l'objectif de 2 degrés mais ils ne
prennent pas les moyens de l'atteindre
après donc c'est atteindre aussi
l'objectif
et ça on est loin du compte on a
beaucoup trop d'émissions horizon 2020
par rapport à ce qu'il faudrait pour
rester sur cette trajectoire
donc l'état a un rôle important à jouer
il a aussi un rôle important à jouer
comme au niveau national ou
international où c'est ça je veux dire
et puis au niveau national toutes les
collectivités ont un rôle important à
jouer parce que où se passent les choses
et bien les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui sont liés soit croit
l'urbanisme au bâti et celles qui sont
liées au transport se sont beaucoup de
décisions qui se prennent au niveau
local au niveau des communautés
d'agglomération au niveau de ses plans
climat énergie qui se met en place
et puis aussi des entreprises parce qu'
il dise où on est dans un monde où je
crois que c'est dans l'économie bien sûr
est importante donc la seule façon de
gagner techniquement c'est possible des
lunes par exemple et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent se développer
elles peuvent nous fournir pratiquement
toute l'énergie qu'on souhaiterait en
tout cas certainement la moitié en 2050
chaleur + électricité donc techniquement
c'est possible mais bien sûr les
industries ne s'y engageront de façon
déterminée que que si ces gagnants et
c'est ça qu'il faut mettre donc il faut
mettre en place
bien sûr mais les industries des
industriels doivent participer doivent
s'engager il faut vraiment que nous
arrêtions d'être ils ont accroché à
l'utilisation du compte suppose il
techniquement c'est possible bien sûr
que les entreprises ont un joué un rôle
et nous aussi en tant que citoyen la
première partie du débat sur la
transition énergétique
on va regarder la demande discuter de la
sobriété bien sûr la demande va être
importante donc on a on a aussi un rôle
à jouer en tant que dix ans chacun
d'entre nous dans cette lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
on a parlé du protocole de kyoto de
kyoto brièvement donc la première phase
s'achève ya quand même il ya eu un
certain sens mais la seconde phase
commence mais de façon extrêmement
disons sans véritable ambition puisque
seule l'europe l'australie dont moins de
15 ans après 15 % des émissions sont
concernés par cette deuxième phase du
protocole de kyoto entre 2013 et 2020
les autres pays éventuellement ce sont
des engagements volontaires mais je n'ai
rien concernant volontaire mais il faut
qu'ils soient ambitieux et là ce sont
des engagements volontaires qui ne sont
pas ambitieux c'est le cas des états
unis qui a simplement dit on s'est
engagé à lever ses misions 3% par
rapport à 1990 voilà donc c'est pas
suffisant et on sait très bien ce que
que si on ne change pas sa trajectoire
et bien on ira vers des échauffements
très importants ils ont dans la deuxième
partie du 21e siècle écoutés merci en
tout cas j'en jouais pour cet éclairage
et merci d'avoir répondu aux questions
de télé fille personnes conférence avons
merci merci ma fille